hi welcome to Hannity and we start
tonight a Fox News Alert you are not
dreaming this is not some horrific
nightmare at this hour the Schumer ship
sham show by the way try and say that
three times fast we're not on a delay
national TV it's kind of going up to bat
there's no net and I'm on the high wire
anyway it's still going on but I have a
lot of good news we start with tonight
none of this will matter because in 286
days you we the American people you I
can report tonight will be the ultimate
jury in all of this I don't have a
crystal ball I can't predict the future
I'm Irish always worried the next bomb
is coming the election is never easy for
a Republican you have to thread the
needle I'm going to go through why I
think the president's in a very good
position but you have the power and 286
days to shock the world again you are
the American people I can report tonight
the ultimate jury and coming up tonight
we're going to show you a major new poll
puts the president way ahead of every
opponent in one very key important state
first in case you were hard at work like
most Americans today and taking care of
your families and paying your taxes and
obeying the laws well here's what you
missed from today's schumer chef sham
show charade made it again we learned
absolutely nothing new today not one new
piece of information instead we got
hours and hours and hours literally of
the compromised corrupt congenital liar
Adam Schiff Wow never-ending non-stop
feigned moral outrage from frankly
watching him today he is a lunatic if
you watched him today well he was
totally unhinged he looked like a
lunatic who's lost his mind
babbling repeating over and over and
over and over again incoherently I
suspect this guy was talking to sleep
Russia Trump Trump Russia quid pro quo
and Peach and Peach and Peach he's like
having a psychotic meltdown for the
entire world to see
and his champions in the meteor he's so
good I'm like okay that's why nobody
watches your shows and worst of all he's
monotonous repetitive boring for three
long horrific hours he waged the single
most crooked lying dishonest smear
campaign the likes of which even for
Washington took my breath away he is a
national disgrace staying on the
Democratic Party a walking talking lying
conman a perfect representation of
everything that is wrong in the DC swamp
it's just a small sample of his neurosis
psychosis mental breakdown today that is
an attempt to use the powers of the
presidency to cheat in an election for
precisely this reason the president's
misconduct cannot be decided at the
ballot box in other words to cheat in
cheating an election they knew what it
was like to live under a despot in 2016
then candidate Trump implored Russia to
hack his opponents email accounts when
the president said hey Russia if you're
listening they were listening Russia
Russians Russian Russian Russian Russian
Russian it's crazy crazy crazy crazy
crazy yeah right word of the day that is
the guy that Democrats want you to trust
really
every time this man for over three years
has opened his mouth he's light and not
just last night not this today shift got
caught in another major lie another one
as it turns out political reporting he
completely mischaracterized the sketchy
new evidence that Democrats tacked on
after on the articles of impeachment in
the 29th hour and to that all the major
lies we've been telling you about the
mall we've shown you again and again and
you have to ask why on earth I don't
think anybody does trust this well
psychotic hack now we all know about as
Russia collusion fixation hoax lies he
wrote a whole report
Evan Nunez told you the truth completely
we know about his FISA abuse lie we know
about him lying about the president's
phone call with Solinsky we know he lied
about the fake so-called hearsay
whistleblower we'd love to hear from him
oh this whole team was communicating
with the hearsay whistleblower from the
get-go
and speaking of which breaking tonight
Paul Sperry Wow big blockbuster breaking
news real clear investigations he has
now dropped a major bomb shell on the
psychotic and lying congenital liar
according to his damning new report the
deep state was a blower was working
closely with shifts office that's why
he's compromised in this case was
overheard only two weeks after Donald
Trump was inaugurated scheming with
another fellow Obama holdover in the
White House how to remove the duly
elected president from office Wow I'd
say it's time for another investigation
now
that was three years ago in 2017 days
after President Trump was just sworn
into office you're president you elected
him we elected him the people you see
what's happening here all of this
charade is now playing out in the swamp
in the sewer in Capitol Hill it has
nothing to do with the president's phone
call with Ukraine they never mentioned a
date was never withheld or any foreign
election interference the only real
interference is Hillary Clinton's bought
and paid for
debunked Russian dirty dossier New York
Times even said oh yeah that was likely
Russian disinformation from the get-go
media got it all wrong we got it right
thankfully on this show with a great
team behind the scenes and our ensemble
cast talk about abuse of power
obstruction of Congress no this is now a
culmination
this is where it's serious this is
hurting the country a years-long
political scheme seeking revenge to
prevent the president's re-election in
286 days now tonight if Democrats if
they're really concerned with election
interference you need to look no further
than in a mirror because the Schumer
ship sham show is just their latest
attempt to reclaim power at any cost
they haven't done anything for you we
the people what have they done they even
complain when we take out the number one
state sponsor of terror was killed
hundreds of Americans even that Donald
Trump cured cancer what have I always
said they'd impeach him for that
yesterday's stream of never-ending
monotonous dull boring redundant talking
points can you imagine 24 hours of this
ship coming up
you know they had these procedural votes
we covered it last night what was one of
these votes about we knew each side
would have 24 hours just like in the
clinton case we knew that there'd be 16
hours of questions it's like in the
clinton case and we knew that after that
was all done then we'd have a vote on
witnesses but they went vote after vote
we need witnesses that we never
subpoenaed in the house was the sole
power impeach you know what that was
that was a political play as well this
is all an act to show that they're
they're putting on for the American
people in prime time and there was
schumer trying to get swing state
senators Oh
Joni Ernst Cory Gardner Susan Collins
they want to tie him into a votes and
then they can run negative ads to try
and beat them and get power back so they
can give us a 94 trillion dollar new
Green Deal and they can give us a 52
trillion dollars Medicare for all we
only take him for trillion a year
somebody please give them an abacus or a
computer or calculators so they can
actually do the math because they can
never fulfill those promise had it
Obamacare keep your doctor plan and save
$2,500 a year per family workout this is
these are promises that are
unsustainable that can never be
fulfilled this is about their power they
want power back they don't like it
Donald Trump this is what draining the
swamp looks like they want now that
desperate they want all three branches
of government they can finally pass yeah
Medicare for all the trillion by T four
trillion dollar new Green Deal the oil
and gas no combustion engine no cows or
planes
everything's free that will bankrupt our
great country and turn our country into
a socialist hellhole remember when we
had fighting Obama eight years we had 13
million more Americans on food stamps
eight million more in poverty lowest
labor participation rate since the 70s
and worse recovery since the 40s look at
every record this president has made in
three years he's now just begun his
fourth year in office but because their
ideas are
failures guaranteed mathematically
impossible to fulfill
well Democrats following the Al Green
playbook their weaponizing the political
system with dirty political tricks lies
propaganda misinformation they've done
nothing in three long years except eight
the president now we've had to endure
and suffer and witness over the past 48
hours house managers and their
Democratic allies in the Senate it's
repulsive it's sickening it's hurting
the country and just after midnight well
president Trump's White House Counsel
Pat Saloni
ripped them to shreds as they deserved
and I would have more words for them
I'll never be allowed in that room
take a look mr. Nadler came up here and
made false allegations against our team
he made false allegations against all of
you he accused you of a cover-up the
only one who should be embarrassed mr.
Nadler is you for the way you've
addressed this body this is the United
States Senate you're not in charge here
it's about time we bring this powertrip
in for a landing mr. Nadler you owe an
apology to the President of the United
States and his family you owe an apology
to the Senate but most of all you owe an
apology to the American people mr.
sepiol only I've known you a long time
you're a brilliant lawyer you Jay
Sekulow your team's been amazing don't
hold your breath
earlier today the president had this to
say about his attorneys powerful moment
also had a few choice words for the
Democratic impeachment managers
president was in Davos where all the
world leaders were sucking up to him the
envy of the free world because we have
the defining growing economy and they
don't want this president because they
take him seriously going after better
trade deals with their countries so
they've trying to play nice in the
sandbox with your president because
there's a deep respect and belief that
what
means what he says he means that he'll
do take a look Jerrold Nadler I've known
him a long time he's a sleazebag
everybody knows that Pat Sippel Oney is
a high quality human being I was very
impressed with Paddy a great emotion
yesterday I Pat's a brilliant guy but
I've never seen that emotion and that's
real emotion that's because he knows
this is a hoax and I was very proud of
the job he did I'm assuming the
president probably had like an hour and
a half sleep and he gave a great press
conference I watched the whole thing
this morning I don't sleep much either
but Mike Lyndell is my pillow does help
now I'm told my my my cracker just that
Adam Schiff is again he's back doing it
more now if I was a terrible host
I would force you to endure watching the
regurgitation the repetition you can put
it up for a second just put it up the
insanity that has gone on all day
America 24 hours of never ending
babbling repetitive talking points over
what was nothing and by the way remember
we sent the new evidence about harness
over to the Senate in the 29th hour in
that letter he said Oh Joe quid pro quo
Joe and hunter zero experience hunter
who paid millions got the prosecutor
fire they did nothing wrong
really okay keep talking to yourself no
matter what happens in the coming days
always remember Congressman Jim Jordans
for irrefutable facts they will never
change you will join us 1 we have a
transcript of the phone conversation
President released actually two phone
conversations with him and president
Zaleski zolensky
aid was never mentioned there was never
any linkage between Biden u.s. aid in
the call number two Jim Jordan both
Trump and President Solinsky said there
was no pressure zero pressure linkage
whatsoever they said it numerous times
including the foreign minister of
Ukraine three this is an important one
the time of the call Ukraine didn't know
the aid was even paused now while the
president didn't talk about eight he did
say now you're surrounding yourself with
a bunch of bad people like your
predecessor that's not good
you're looking out for your tax dollars
do us a favor
America Ukraine okay if you've
interfered you know Russia interfered
Devin Nunez they should have listened to
them in 2014 but if you're Ukrainian
Court in Politico January 11 2017 is
correct well they have a chronology of
election interference Ukraine was
involved then you need to get to the
bottom of that well for three years
Democrats said foreign election
interference is bad by the way number
four
Jim Jordans hits the Ukrainians took no
action nothing to get the aid released
there's no announcement of any
investigation and Abidin no promise of
any investigation we have the letters
the invitation of Solinsky to come to
the White House the aid was released on
time actually early for some of it
and there's one other point there were
five high-level meetings after that call
including the vice president at not one
of those meetings did anyone ever talk
about eight the only one fact witness
that would be ambassador Sandlin
he said yeah the president said I don't
want anything no quid pro quo just you
know don't be corrupt still Democrats
claim their case is overwhelming for
impeachment now if that were true they
wouldn't need the Senate now to do what
is constitutionally their job and look
for we need new evidence of we need to
subpoena witnesses we didn't bother to
subpoena because we were in an urgent
rush before Christmas was to go on
vacation and then hide it for another
couple of weeks so there was such a
danger to our our democratic republic
now Democrats have nothing had nothing
there at the end of the road and as I
said at the top of the show thank God I
am well happy about one thing American
people you will render the ultimate
verdict now you have people like liberal
Joe over there at the conspiracy channel
saying that well maybe Hannity lives in
a bubble there's no chance Donald Trump
can win okay oh if that's the case I
live with Obama for eight years but I
would like to see America and every
record continue I would like to see guys
like Soleimani beg daddy and the Isis
Caliphate continue to be wiped out I
would like to see the the continuation
of record numbers low unemployment was
the
since 1969 continued for our fellow
Americans every demographic
african-americans asian-americans
Hispanic Americans women in the
workplace youth unemployment I'd like
that to continue I don't want to go back
to the horrific obama-biden years I
don't want to be bribing mullahs with a
hundred and fifty billion in cash you
know the currency all of this is is
politics they want power back for what
to destroy the economy again and bribe
dictators again and mullahs again
now there is one barometer that we pay
attention to in this business and I
thankfully you give me this this camera
every night that's right in front of me
you give me a microphone for three hours
a day Wow
the only way I continue to work is if
you watch and listen well there were TV
ratings from last night's coverage
so-called trial of the century day one
well minor increases across the board
minor wasn't a lot of interest like they
thought a matter of fact
CBS's actually ended their impeachment
coverage early today by the way thank
you for making us number one last night
and the last number of years thank you I
can't do it without you but CBS did it
because they wanted their regularly
scheduled daytime soap operas back if
they make money on those and meanwhile
the president he was doing what he
always does he was in Europe conducting
important business over the last three
years Democrats in the media and the mob
their state-run TV propagandists well
they raged the president he's been a
busy man here's a brief recap of what
he's accomplished in less than one term
let's take a look the Forgotten men and
women of our country will be forgotten
no longer the time for empty talk is a
now arrives the hour of action from this
day forward a new vision will govern our
from this day
it's going to be only America first
every decision will be made to benefit
American workers and American family
America will start winning again winning
like never before
I will fight for you with every breath
in my
never ever
allow anyone to tell you that it cannot
be done no challenge can match the heart
and fight and spirit of America
we will not fail
our country will thrive and prosper
again
you
[Music]
unstoppable I saw dance Kiev oh who
works for the president tweeted and
everything in there is true the
do-nothing Democrats have done nothing
but in the president's case promises
made promises kept all Americans are now
winning I'm not sick of winning